now let me see if I can remember the
control
tally they've targeted the swagan Monica
Duke assembling Lachlan Cinco Oscar
isn't seen this is he
you cannot escape the pole I don't know
how to react
you cannot escape the pole
[Music]
that sounded
know their bio hexa crepes Ari scrambled
every hour no bio hexaco know their bio
hexa Krypton re scrambled every out well
their bio hexa Krypton e and know their
bio head know their bio hex their bio
hectic Krypton no no their bio exit Peck
sorry like a woman I tell you sakes you
know what if I feel like grandpa Simpson
now yeah I'm let me get out of the
cockpit I don't know what's going on oh
there's the old targeting device no I
don't need that you can move it
wait for what we can mold it 50 I take 2
take 3
[Music]
[Music]
you're demoted
[Applause]
[Music]
where did it come from this whole place
is beautiful
sorry I got something hanging out my bum
[Music]
you have to give Finn and Poe that's me
[Music]
that was ousted that's the tape all
right well thanks for the memories
[Music]
you